right thank you so much
uh you're setting the bar very high for
this presentation so let me see if i can
i can meet that bar
so it's a true pleasure to be here
thanks for having me and thanks for for
attending the talk
uh as she said i'm luca carlon i'm an
associate professor at mit and the goal
for today is really to share some of the
ongoing work
is doing on uh going towards certifiable
spatial perception
systems and algorithms
so maybe a good way to start this
presentation is just to tell a little
bit about my group and the director of
spark club at mit spark stands for
sensing perception autonomy and robot
kinetics
and of course we work in the broad area
of robotics and autonomous systems but
we particularly focus on
robot perception and vision-based
navigation
so what you see in this slide are the
three big research areas we're working
on
we work on
robust and certifiable perception
we are going to hear about this a bit in
this presentation
ranging from problems such as visual
inertial navigation simultaneous
localization and mapping to problems
like you know including object detection
and pos estimation
then we focus on high level scene
understanding or what people in the
community are calling spatial ai i'm
going to talk a lot about this today
and then there is one last research area
which i'm not going to touch today is
about co-design is work at the boundary
within perception in other areas of
robotics including
control communication mechanical design
and so on uh is an area i'm super
excited about you have the cool work on
soft aerial manipulation we just won
best paper award with tyros last year on
this i just will not have time to to go
into the details of that so before we
even start with the with the technical
contributions i just want to start by
saying that all the work that you're
going to see today is really the result
of amazing work done my my students and
postdocs in in my group so it's really
like you know this is to give credits to
them for uh um
putting so much effort and for getting
like you know good results out of their
research
so the plan for this presentation is
still to cover two big ideas i want to
cover the work we are doing on what we
call spatial perception systems
this high level is just an effort to go
from traditional mapping robotics to
real time 3d scene understanding
so the first part is mostly going to be
high level and about systems so you
you're going to see a lot of system uh
work
but then in the second part of the
presentation i'm going to zoom in on the
algorithms and the second part is going
to be a little bit more mathematical not
too much but i'm going to zoom in a
little bit on the algorithms and then of
course i will conclude and discuss open
problems
so the size of these boxes are
reflecting a bit what is the duration of
each part i'm going to spend most of the
time on the first part
then i will jump in for maybe 10 or 15
minutes to this and then i will conclude
so let me start by discussing the work
we're doing on spatial perception and
again this effort we're going from
mapping to real time through this in
understanding
um the basic motivation for this work
and for our effort in thinking about
real-time reducing understanding is the
realization that there is still a large
gap separating robot perception from
human perception
over the last decade we made impressive
progress in robot perception for example
right now we have good algorithms for
dramatic understanding thanks to the
progress in simultaneous localization
and mapping we have really real-time
algorithms that can process sensor data
in building real-time without prior
knowledge a 3d geometric model of the
environment such as a large scale point
cloud a voxel-based representation for
example
at the same time with deep learning we
made impressive progress in 2d semantic
understanding right you have algorithms
and architectures such as yolo which are
able to detect bounding boxes of objects
in the images or we have even networks
to do
pixel wise segmentation as the one that
you see in this image in which for each
pixel will be able to assign a semantic
label to the corresponding pixel
at the same time we have to realize that
as humans we do much more than that
and to convince you that the human
perception is much more than just
magic understanding a little bit
and a bit of semantic understanding i
just have to show you a single picture
okay so as a human if you started the
picture on the right for a few seconds
you can quickly understand what is the
geometry of the sea right you can
understand that there is a road there
are buildings you can understand what is
the semantic of the scene for example
there are cars pedestrians and you can
also reason over the 3d location of
these objects
and you can think about relations within
different objects for example you can
think about the fact that the car is
driving on the street or that the car is
approaching the traffic
so this kind of 3d scene understanding
which is captioning at the same time
geometry semantic segregation in a very
holistic way is something that is still
missing for for robotics
well but the question is why do we care
about these in the first place why is it
is this kind of 3dc understanding
important for robotics and i'm going to
argue that the reason is twofold
first of all high-level 3ds in
understanding is key to interaction
if our robot is only able to understand
geometry our robot is doom
is doomed to execute low-level geometric
instructions for example the robot will
be able to execute commands such as
robot go to position x y and z
but personally theft to picture the next
generation of robots i would like for
them to be smarter than that i would
like for the robots to be able to
execute high-level instructions such as
robots will grab me the cup of coffee on
the table in the kitchen
and for the robot to parse and execute
this complex instruction
the robot will we need to know about
geometry right we need to know
how to get to the kitchen
we need to know about semantics what is
a cup of coffee what is the table and we
need to reason all the relations what
does it mean for the cup of coffee to be
on the table and for the table to be
within the kitchen
so 3d scene understanding is key to
interaction
even more so
high levels in understanding is key to
robustness
in particular i'm going to argue that
any robust perception system
must listen over geometry semantics and
relations in 3d
and i'm going to give you just a simple
example for instance imagine that i show
you this image these slides and i just
like to detect an object detect the car
in this image of course i can detect the
car
but if then i look at the broader
context surrounding the image of the car
i realized that in the middle of the
image this is not a physical car right
it is a picture of a car on the
billboard
and this conclusion is easy for human
perception because as humans we reason
over the
geometric cues for example you reason
over the fact that this car is too far
from the road to be a physical car
we use over the semantics of this object
which is a billboard and we also reason
over the relations between the billboard
and the car
uh essentially the billboard and the car
cannot occupy the same physical space
that for one should be painted on the
other okay so corrects in understanding
is really relying on simultaneous
understanding geometry semantics
relations including
so you might argue that uh actually this
kind of uh
specific images are not going to trick
modern perception systems but i can
provide two examples to tell you that
actually modern perception systems are
not really as advanced as you might
think
and just by chance like for instance
both examples are from tesla um this is
one like you know from june 2021
and what happens is that the autopilot
is detecting a bunch of traffic lights
right but if you look at the actual
scene
um what happens is that these are not
physical traffic lights but they are
just uh traffic lights which are carried
by truck
and of course for the perception system
to correctly understand the scene the
perception system i must reason over the
relations between different objects must
reason over the relations between the
traffic lights and the track
rather than doing just object detection
in isolation
and of course that you know if you look
at recent news and the news about
phantom breaking from tesla you really
realize that the state-of-the-art
interception systems is really far from
the type of robustness that we get
with the with human
perception the first contribution that i
want to cover today is really what we
are doing on designing spatial really
the first kind of spatial perception
systems for 3ds in understanding that
are able to reason over geometry
semantics relations in real time
and i'm going to provide kind of a
sequence of system of increasing
complexity starting from early work on
chimera which many of you have seen
already
do very recent work called hydra which
we just released a couple of weeks ago
and this is actually the first time i'm
going to present the results of of these
systems
so but let me start with kimera he
marries an early attempt at doing
essentially listening over geometry and
semantics at the same time in real time
so what is kimera kimera is a system
which is taking as input
sensor data from a standard camera so
there is a sequence of images as well as
inertial data
there is an army on the camera
and its output kimaera is building what
is called the 3dmatic semantic model so
what you see here is not just a plain
video is a 3d model
in which the geometry is described as a
mesh as a 3d mesh
and each phase of the mesh is
colored by semantic label so for example
gray stands for ground
dark green corresponds to the walls
light greens the chairs so each color is
a different semantic label
and what i want to do in the next couple
of slides is really give you like you
know just a big picture about what's
inside chemera and tell you about the
latest experiments that we've been
making with this system
probably the first other information
here is that camera is open source so if
you want to try this for yourself you
can just go on github and find out
everything is open source you have a
good and fast implementation
so how do we get this kind of magic
semantic mapping capability um well
timer is taking sensor data as input as
i said and the first thing that we try
to do is that we totally construct the
trajectory of the robot moving in the
environment remember that in this kind
of systems we assume no prior knowledge
of the environment so the robot is
starting from scratch building a map of
the environment
and the first step is what is called
visual inertial odometry essentially
chemist solving an optimization problem
to reconstruct from images
the trajectory of the robot moving in
the environment and is also
reconstructing the 3d location of points
which you see in green which are
observed in the image
so this is based on something that is
called any pre-integration theory which
is something that we developed a few
years ago at this point
and the result of this module is really
an automatic estimate of the trajectory
of the robot
this automatic estimate is then past the
second module which is called camera
semantics which will be in charge of
building this map around the trajectory
estimate of the robot
so the mapping part is just a basin
inference over a box at this
representation
and the inference is brought about
inferring the
occupancy state of the voxel as well as
a semantic label for the voxels and
after this voxel-based representation is
built anything can be quickly converted
into a mesh using standard algorithms
such as marching tubes
the thing that really stands out for
kimaera is that all of this mapping is
done in real time on a cpu-based
parallel implementation so we are not
using too much
computational resource in this case just
because it's a pure cpu based
implementation
and finally what happens is that the
automatic estimate will drift over time
just because it's a source of odometry
right so we have a final module which is
chimera post graph optimization or
better robust photograph optimization
which is in charge of correcting the
trajectory in response to loop closures
so for those of you are not working
islam or perception what it means like
you know what is a loop closure imagine
that the robot is navigating the
environment and what you see is the
automatic estimate of the trajectory
which accumulates over time
what happens is that at two different
times the robot might be seeing the same
portion of the environment so maybe
he's seeing part of the kitchen at this
pose and part of the kitchen this other
pose and this allows to create kind of
these loop closure constraints which are
enabling the correction of the
trajectory
so let me play this again the trajectory
the automatic trajectory is different
drifting over time and if you're able to
detect these loop closures you can
correct the trajectory and make it more
accurate
so what really stands out in ximena is
that we have an approach for doing this
correction which again is called
postgraph optimization which is really
robust outliers because in practice many
of these loop closures are produced by
class recognition techniques which are
really prone to failure and in chimera
we have robust installed liars which is
enabled by one of the certifiable
algorithms i'm going to discuss in the
second part of the talk
and on top of correcting the trajectory
of the robot we also have a new
technique i'm not going to discuss that
too much but we have a technique to also
correct the 3d mesh
in response to loop closure which is a
method that we call postgraph and mesh
optimization
so that's like slide overview of camera
everything is running on cpu here and
everything is running at real time and
hopefully you are going to have a
release 2.0 of of this library uh later
this spring
what i want to do next is really to
showcase some of the recent results we
have in deploying these systems on both
simulation for realistic simulations in
real data
and i'm going to showcase actually one
of the uh
challenging results or like you know
challenging demonstrations in which we
are even running chimera simultaneously
on multiple robots so we have three
robots in this case they are driving in
simulation
and they are estimating their own
trajectories that you see in yellow is
not super visible but they are also
building this metric semantic mesh in
which each color corresponds to
different semantic classes
okay and when the robots appear in these
closures maybe when the robots are
meeting each other they perform this
post-graph optimization to correct the
trajectory and potentially correct the
mesh
so these work done in collaboration with
the group of john hull
and
for those of you who don't believe in
simulation we have also very cool real
experiments with chimera still in this
case i'm showing just for fun and
experiment with three robots running
fiemera
and i'm starting to show just the
trajectory estimates the trajectory
estimates will drift because of
the visually inertial automatic with
liftover time
but as long as there are loop closures
whenever there is a loop closure the
trajectory gets corrected
and the result is that the trajectory
gets better and better over time which
is something that you see qualitatively
in the video but also you can see in the
numbers like in the table these are
localization errors or trajectory
estimation addressing meters
the va errors are quite large because
these are very long trajectories
but after loop closure you can reduce
the error by a large amount and you can
get an error
in the order of centimeters at this
point
the last part of this video is also
showing the postgraph and mesh
optimization which is a cool aspect of
chimera in which you deform and you
correct at the same time both the
trajectory of the robots as well as the
mesh reconstruction
around the robots and you can see that
whenever there is a loop closure this
mesh gets the mesh constructed by the
three robots
gets corrected and deformed more and
more
until it converges to a nice 3d
reconstruction of the environment has it
up and selection at the end of the of
the result
okay so so we have this approach which
in this case is without semantics but
chimera in general is a magic semantic
slam library that is running real time
and this is work that we have done over
the last like a few years
but when we proposed this technique um a
while back
we realized okay this is great this real
time works nicely but you also realize
the fact that
the type of mesh representation that you
get out of chemera is not necessarily
the best representation for robotics
first of all it's kind of
of difficult to do planning essentially
with this representation it's difficult
to do motion planning for example over a
mesh
and this representation is also quite
large so maybe it's not really um
allowing to capture all the information
is not even capturing relations among
different objects which is one of the
motivation we started from we wanted to
capture also relations geometry and
semantics
so this motivated us to go towards the
second idea which is the idea of 3d
dynamic sync graphs
free dynamic sync graphs are essentially
a hierarchical map representation
is a new type of map representation
which is storing
which is modeling the environment as is
a graph
and what i'm going to do here is to
explain the video in a second the video
on the left and then we're going to go
together through the details on the
right
so what is a three dynamic scene graph
is a graph hierarchical graph
representation in which there are
multiple layers
and the basic idea is that the lowest
layer you have
just sematic semantic mesh which is the
same that you got with kimera
but the more you go up in the layers the
more you obstruct away the low-level
geometry into high-level semantic
concepts
for example a liar ii you capture
objects and agents
right without worrying about the entire
mesh you just isolate objects regions
at layer 3 you detect places and
structures
places essentially a collision-free
location the robot can move to while
structures are ceiling walls and so on
and you can go up for indoor
environments into segmented rooms
buildings and so on
so more formally a td dynamic signal is
a directed graph where nodes represent
spatial concepts and ages represent
spatial temporal relations within
concepts
so why this is a powerful representation
well first of all we finally are able to
capture relation among different objects
which we saw was a kind of a key to high
level understanding
second for those of you are familiar
with mapping for robotics this
representation is unifying metric maps
such as the mesh at the bottom layer
with topological maps so the graph of
places is just a topological map of the
environment
moreover this kind of representation is
starting to capture objects rooms
buildings phases so this representation
is really suitable for uh motion
planning task planning and just decision
making for robotics
so something that i must say when giving
a talk at stanford is that actually
pioneering work on 3d scene graph comes
from stanford so the first paper on 3d
synthrops
is from the group of jitendra in silvio
that at mit was led by iron man and what
we are doing here is to propose a
version which is more geared to a rope
towards robotics so we are changing a
little bit the structure to make it more
useful for robotics and we are
developing real-time algorithms to enter
this kind of representation if they have
time from sensor data
so in terms of building this
representation from sensor data the
first attempt we tried was what what
what we call chimera vsg chimera dynamic
sync graph
and i will tell you high level what
camera dsg was doing and i will conclude
that this actually was not a real time
approach and this will motivate me to
progress to to describe the last system
which instead is going to be a real time
system but let's look at this first
attempt
so in the first attempt to be the sigra
from data
we essentially use sensor data we fed
that to chemera to build the layer one
which is the magic semantic mesh
but then we also added algorithms to
build the other layers for example we
added algorithms to build
vf2 which is the layer of agents
and we did that by mixing deep learning
image based
human pose estimation with deep learning
with postgraph optimization for tracking
of humans over time
and the result is what you see in this
video we're able to detect
dense models of humans moving in front
of the robot and we're able to track the
motion of humans
as they move through the environment
moreover we're also able to isolate
objects and detect objects as part of
the mesh
the detection of the object depends on
whether we have
some shape information about the object
or not
if we do not have shape information we
just fit the bounding box if you have
some shape information for the object
that we are detecting from the mesh we
just do some
registration algorithm which is one of
the algorithms certifiable algorithms
i'm going to describe later in the talk
and finally um the scene graph also has
places and rooms
the places are really just forming a
skeleton of the environment
so what is the graph of places is a
graph in which nodes are free space
location and edges represent
traversability from one place to the
other
and in order to deconstruct the places
here what we do is that we take a
voxel-based representation and we just
uh compute what is called a generalized
coronoid diagram to extract this
graph of places and then we do some
sorry then we do some graph clustering
algorithm
we get there
we do some graph clustering algorithm to
isolate the rooms from the graph of
places and to cluster the different
rooms
so with this initial system camera dsg
we already got very compelling
demonstrations of like you know building
3d signals from from data is the one
that is in this video
the main issue with this system is that
we were able to build singaps but uh it
took several minutes essentially to
build a singer was not compatible with
real-time operation
and there were two quite fundamental
challenges to solve to make this into a
real-time system
the first challenge is that
to build the graphical places and to
segment rooms essentially our system
relied on processing of a monolithic
voxel-based representation a huge
voxel-based representation of the entire
environment and that kind of processing
over large voxel-based representation
was not compatible simply with real-time
operation
and then the same the second challenge
is that uh remember that when your robot
is navigating in real time
keeps getting these loop closures and
keeps correcting the trajectory it's on
trajectory estimated response group
closures
which means that whenever you're a
trajectory change you will need to
reconstruct the single from scratch
at least with the first approach here we
will need to reconstruct the singer from
scratch which is simply incompatible
with real-time operation
so this brings me to the last system i
want to discuss today which is sunny
that we proposed and we released online
like a couple of weeks ago which is
hydra which is the first system for uh
constructing 3d scene graphs from sensor
data in real time
here what you see is the architecture
for hydra i don't want you to parse like
all the details of the architecture i
just want to give you a couple of
insights about what's what's inside this
architecture
and the first insight is that
3d scene understanding really involves
asynchronous perception processes
running at different rates for example
if you want to do a 3d scene
understanding you will have to do some
image processing
and some low-level perception tasks
which have to run very fast
and they are just running at sensor rate
you have to combine these with the
tasks such as for example mesh
reconstruction or visually natural
dominantly which are what we call
mid-level perception processes
which can run a little bit slower and
can reason over short time horizon
and then you always end up having high
level perception processes which have to
reason over the entire map and some of
the the mass is lower because they have
reason over the entire map
so really because of this presence of
multiple perception processes which are
asynchronous that are planning at
different rates
a key
tool that you have to deploy is that we
have to make
our perception system highly
parallelized just to enable real-time
operation
the second challenger inside is that
again we we cannot really hope to
rebuild a 3d singer from scratch after
loop closure because that will really
prevent real-time operation
and to avoid building a single from
scratch after loop closure we propose a
new technique which we call 3d scene
graph optimization
which is just correcting the scene graph
every time there is a loop closure in
the trajectory of the robot
so let me show you a couple of features
of hydra
first of all i want to show you how this
works when building incrementally the
sim graph hydra will use
something that is similar to chimera in
building a metric semantic mesh of the
environment but at the same time we'll
just keep a voxel-based representation
around the robot position we'll never
reconstruct an entire voxel-based
representation
in the same time from from the mesh
we'll extract in real-time the objects
and we fit bounding boxes to the objects
and then when it comes to the places
we'll use some by-products of the
integration of of the voxel-based
representation
on the fly to reconstruct the graph of
places which again are forming a
topological map of the environment
and then we apply a community detection
algorithm to cluster the graph into
different rooms and you can see that the
rooms here in red and the magenta violet
here are matching the terms in the
reconstruction
so to enable these again we have new
algorithms based on computer community
detection as well as a highly
parallelized architecture
but really the technical aspect of hydra
that i want to to showcase here is this
idea of 3d single graph optimization
which is optimizing the scene graph in
response to loop closures
so imagine that you have your robot
which is building a scene graph
including the poses of the robot
the graph of places which are in blue
ends reconstructing some 3d mesh
and imagine that the robot at some point
gets a loop closure as the dashed line
that you see over here
the basic idea here is that in response
to this loop closure we can solve a
single optimization problem which is
trying to recompute
the position of the matrices of the mesh
as well as the position of the places
and robot
such that we essentially accommodate the
loop closure while avoiding to deform
the geometry of the scene too much
okay so we just solved like you know
last optimization problem
and actually we do that using a old
technique from computer vision which is
called deformation graphs deformation
graphs is essentially sampling the mesh
into just a subset of vertices and is
forming a graph of different nodes and
we can solve an optimization problem to
recompute what is the test
location of these nodes given the
problem constraints for example given
the the
odometry of the robot given the
loop closure and given some constraints
on the local geometry of the problem
so in the paper what we do is to show
that not only we can solve this kind of
optimization problem close to real time
in a matter of few seconds but we also
show that this problem can be formulated
again as postgraph optimization which is
again a standard problem in robotics so
you have
existing seconds of this optimization
problem very efficiently and there are
off the shelf
so let me show you just a real
demonstration of hydra which i think is
pretty destructive so this is a
real environment uh we're using high to
map a student residence at mit
the
camera is going through two floors so
there is a floor one then there are the
stairs and there is a second floor
and um what you see on the left are the
images some of them are just
removed if there is a person just for
privacy reasons and there is a semantic
segmentation from a neural network
and you see the 3d reconstruction from
either the scene graph on the right and
a top view here on the left
and one of the parts which is more
impressive to me is what happens um let
me pause this for a second
so you see that the trajectory is kind
of drifting over time because again it's
doing visually natural automatic
estimated trajectory and that is
drifting over time
but when the robot is coming back to a
location that we have seen before
we'll essentially do this 3d sync graph
optimization
and we'll correct the entire scene graph
and
the map reconstruction with a single
optimization problem which i think is
pretty cool
can i ask one question
yes yes i was interested in exactly that
moment what happens and how this
propagates over the hierarchy
and
and so i'm not sure if this is like uh
happening only in the video maybe but
this loop closure does this run in the
background you still integrate incoming
um
information from the robot or and then
how do you link this again to the
maybe corrected
um loop closed map and all of this uh
how does that work it's a good question
like you know the secret here is really
parallelization right you have to make
sure that the processes like uh the
scene graph optimization which is still
fast that is running in a matter of
seconds does not have to interfere with
the real-time operation so there are
multiple different threads
there is a thread which will correspond
to a typical front-end for slam which is
doing sensor processing real-time
and then there is this that every now
and then when there is a loop closure
will get triggered and we solve this
large optimization problem
and to make sure that things remain
compatible what we do is we start an
automatic version of the sigma and then
we start an optimized version of the
scene graph and we make sure these two
are in sync are synchronized every now
and then
okay thanks
very good okay
so um we've been testing these on on
many uh
datasets one more question quickly in
the audience yes yes of course i have
one question regarding it looks like for
now you're working with a single agent
there's a lot of your loop closures
being done on the front end using like
um visual like uh geometric reasoning
methods like uh perception aliasing
is the question if we get spurious loop
closures or what do we use to detect
loop closures
yeah kind of like what uh specific
method you're using for your uh loop
closures like for your geometric
reasoning techniques
yeah it's a great question because
that's another contribution of the paper
that i just skipped over just because
it's much stuff here
you can do just image based um
place recognition and uh and loop
closure detection with bag of words
standard approaches
what we do here is a little bit more we
say
first of all we can detect
hierarchical descriptors right if you
want to do loop closure and you have a
scene graph now you can start telling
the robot
not only you can provide the images but
you can also use another of the objects
surrounding the robot
the geometry of the places surrounding
the the robot the room the robot is
moving in so you can use all these
errors
to make the loop closure detection much
better and indeed what you do is to
define a hierarchical loop closure
and then at the same time when you have
to reconstruct the relative pose for the
loop closure you can do a number of
things you can align the objects right
you can align the images and so on so i
think a short answer to your question is
that we define a suitable hierarchical
descriptor to improve the loop closure
performance
over typical approaches based on image
matching or feature matching
okay i hope that helped
and i suggest like you know really there
are many more details like in the paper
that
i'm i'm skipping over but i just want to
give that big picture of our policies or
at least in school as well as the
results that you are getting on on a
number of data sets put in simulation
and real data
so these are the type of environments we
tested in uh office environments
apartments subway uh student residences
at mit
and uh we're able to do a good job at
reconstructing these synchros you're
going to see a number of the scene graph
that we reconstruct here on the right
they were able to reconstruct even sing
graphs with multiple floors you see that
we have no troubles with stairs and so
on and we can still do a good job at
segmenting the different rooms
um
what i want to stress here just in the
interest of time the only
quantitative result i want to stress
here is the run time so
i'm comparing here the runtime
of chimera dsg which is the first
approach i discussed against hydra and
you can see the camera dsg is just a
complex that grows over time because we
review and revisit again and again the
voxel-based representation
and so this will be becoming practical
impractical over time
and instead for either the runtime again
it's parallelized so there are slow
threads and fast threads but for the
past threads you can do all the
processing in really a matter of
of milliseconds
okay let me wrap up this part i really
have to move on to the certifiable
algorithms what i told you so far can be
understood if you visualize a picture in
which you are plotting perception
systems
and you are looking at efficiency
versus high level understanding
i told you that the state of the art is
really doing
either dramatic understanding or 2d
semantic understanding
and we have pretty efficient systems
which are not very smart they're not
providing high levels in understanding
on the other end we have things like you
know hd maps which will have a lot of
information packed
but they are human annotated so they are
not efficient they are really lucky to
run offline
and what we did is to really push the
boundary of
bridging the gap within current
perception system say human perception
we designed himera which is an effort to
bridge geometric understanding and
semantic understanding
we proposed a first approach for uh to
build dynamic signal which was offline
so it was not very efficient and more
recently we have hydra which is both
efficient and is getting to some sort of
high level understanding of the scene
so as you saw most of the work
represented so far is is really about
systems we are doing there are cool
insights about algorithms but i'm
proposing these as
you know efficient implementation and
putting together a number of
perception problems in a single system
what i want to do next is to zoom in on
some of the algorithms we use and
discuss this idea of certifiable
perception algorithms because these
algorithms which are running in the
background or the perception system i
discussed in the first part of the talk
are really the reason why the perception
systems we are building are working and
they are robust
so um this part is going to be a little
bit more mathematical but again i would
try to give you the ideas without
without throwing too many questions
around
so the first observation is that a
complex perception system requires
solving
many perception problems
including for example object detection
in either point clouds or from images
as well as for example the estimation of
the trajectory of the robot which is
something that before i called postgraph
optimization so for a perception system
we have to solve all these challenges
the nice opportunity here is that
despite the diversity of these problems
from object detection to pose estimation
here
in the background of this perception
problem you end up solving some
optimization problem and that's a
commonality across all these perception
problems
so the type of optimization problem that
you end up solving is something like
this
in which you're trying to estimate a
quantity of interest let's say the x for
example is the pose of the car that you
want to localize
um you are given a bunch of measurements
why i for example the measurements are i
don't know feature detections that you
have from the
image and you're trying to find the x
which is minimizing the residual errors
the residual error is a given function
which is quantifying how well your
estimate is explaining the measurements
and of course in practice you're going
to have
a large set of measurements that you're
given
so this is a very general formulation
for a bunch of perception problems the
unfortunate thing that is preventing
robustness is prevent is making existing
system brittle
is that in practice they're going to
have they're going to be many
measurements y i which are outliers
which are completely wrong
for example if you're doing feature
detection and you want to estimate the
pose of this car
some of the feature detections may be
completely off came completely wrong
and if you're solving this optimization
problem without flyers you're going to
get a bad estimate for the x
so of course like you know we are not
the first to encounter problems without
flyers what we can do is just look at
the literature or robust estimation and
people in robust estimation will tell us
that the solution to
reducing the impact of outliers is to
put a robust loss function in front of
our receivers instead of minimizing the
squared
norm of the residuals we can minimize
the robust loss function raw
and um so we have this general recipe to
have to solve perception these
optimization problems arising in
perception in the presence of outliers
and my question is then why the state of
the art is still brittle why the state
of the art is still suffering from these
outliers
well the reason is simple people in
robust estimation theory they told us
how to formulate the problem right this
is how to estimate the x in a robust way
but they didn't tell us how to solve
this optimization problem
okay what happens is that
for common choices of robust loss
function raw
for example this is a popular one which
is a truncatedly square loss
what happens is that the the cost
function is non-convex this is a
non-convex function
and therefore the overall optimization
problem is a non-convex optimization
problem i'm sure many of you will be
familiar with optimization but
essentially non-convex means that there
are multiple values here
and if
our algorithm is able to get to the
bottom of this cost function we get a
good estimate for the variable we care
about for the position of the car
if the algorithm instead is stuck in
some local minimum
the estimate for the location of the car
is going to be poor
so i can summarize the state of the art
really in a couple of sentences here the
state of japan splits in uh
state of the art in solving this
optimization problem is split between
local solvers which you can think about
for example is gradient descent gauss
newton and so on
which rely on some initial guess and
also are easily stuck in local minima so
that's why they are brittle
on the other end you can use techniques
like ransack which are going to try to
get to the minimum of the cost function
by sampling the measurements uh that you
are given in the problem
but unfortunately ransack will still
feed with high probability if you have
many outliers and for those of you have
played with ransack ransack really
requires a minimum solver so it's mostly
suitable for low dimensional problems
and a shortcoming of both local server
solvers and ransack is that
they will give an estimate for the
quantity you care about and this
estimate can be completely wrong but
will not they will not be able to detect
the failure so they will both fail
without notice
so what you've done over the last few
years is really to think about this idea
of certifiable perception algorithms in
a sentence certifiable perception
algorithms are algorithms to solve
the robust estimation problems that had
in the previous slide like this
optimization problem
and we want to solve these optimization
problems to optimality in polynomial
time or declare failure so either we
solve the problems efficiently or if we
cannot solve the problem we want to
detect that we are not able to resolve
the problem
and these like you know just full
credits this is uh work like my student
hank yang
who is on the job market this year he's
just doing terrific work has been doing
terrific work on this research line
so for this i want to jump a little bit
more into the month so i'm going to have
two or three slides which which will
have a questions but hopefully you will
uh you will see
some very simple message out of these
slides
and i want to tell you what is the
general philosophy that you use in going
from these robust estimation problems is
the one that you see at the top of the
slide
two polynomial time algorithms
essentially the insights that
that we had are just two folders very
simple
the first one is that
a large set of robust estimation
problems in this form
and in particular those arising a robot
perception
can be formulated as polynomial
optimization problems
so for those of you who don't know what
is polynomial optimization problem
polynomial optimization problem is
nothing but an optimization problem in
which both the cost function
and the constraints are polynomials so p
h and g are just polynomial polynomials
in the unknown
x okay and we can have both equality
constraints and inequality constraints
so the first insight is that you can
rewrite this cost function this problem
is a polynomial optimization problem for
a large class of perception problems
and the second insight is that once you
have a polynomial optimization problem
there is a very systematic way to get
a convex relaxation what is called the
moment semi-definite relaxation for the
original problem which is going to solve
the problem for us in polynomial time
so what i want to try today for the
first time i want to try to have a
proof sketch actually for the first
point i want to show that it's actually
simple to convert this problem into
something that is a polynomial
optimization problem
and i want to tell you a little bit
about this idea of moment relaxation
again with a single slide so we'll do my
best just to give it the
the bottom line
so let's start this exercise of
converting this problem into a
polynomial
optimization so again the proof or the
thing that i want to prove with you
today is that i can convert the
statement is that this problem is a
polynomial optimization problem for
common perception problems and for
several choices of loss functions i will
be a bit more precise in a second
and we are going to prove this statement
using three steps
first of all i'm going to claim that
the residual error squared
so r here the residual error squared
is a polynomial in x for many perception
problems
in this summary can be just proven for
respect by spectrum so if you look at
the common perception problem for
example object detection from point
clouds 3d registration absolute cos
estimation and many others
you will look at the structure of these
problems and these typically have some
quadratic objectives or they have a
linear
residual and of course will become a
quadratic function after you take the
norm squared
why is that why is so common of a
pattern in this in these problems
uh the reason why is that the action of
rotations and translation is linear
right and most of these problems are
just rotating quantities around a
different reference frame and again
rotation and translations are linear
operations therefore the resulting
receivers will be just
linear functions and the square
receivables will be quadratic functions
so we proved that the r squared is a
polynomial
uh now we have to prove that the domain
like you know the constraints here which
is this x uh is also can be described as
a set of polynomials
and this is
as a simple thing that typically these
problems involve just reasoning over
translations or rotations
transitions are just vectors so they are
unconstrained
and instead rotations are member of sod
the special orthogonal group
and the expression of the special
orthogonal group camry can be written as
a set of
quadratic equality constraints so bodies
constraints and this which is the
definition of rotation matrix can be
described as quadratic equality
constraints
so in other words typical constraints
involving translations or rotations can
be written as polynomials and it is also
true for other type of constraints for
example field of view constraints
distances and so on so so far i proved
that
these x here can be written as
polynomial constraints these are can be
written as a polynomial
the only thing i'm left is to reason
over this draw
and i'm going to show that also the row
for uh
seven
popular choices of robust loss function
can be written as a polynomial
so the claim here is that the robust
loss row can be written as a polynomial
in the square of the receivable by
introducing extra variables for seven
robust cost functions
and really the proof is relying on this
idea of black regards and duality which
is saying that this optimization problem
where rho is a robust loss function is
equivalent to this optimization problem
in which essentially for each
measurement you are adding a scalar
weight
which you can understand as kind of a
measure of confidence over that
measurement do you trust the measurement
or not
and again there is this black regards on
duality is providing us a very
systematic way to move from this
formulation to this formulation
in the second formulation you see that
as long as r square is polynomial the
first term is a polynomial
and for seven robust functions also the
second term is a polynomial robust loss
functions are truncated squares maximum
consensus german mcclure
uh taki and huber so many popular robust
functions will end up leading to a
polynomial
so hopefully so far like you know with
this very fast proof i just tried to
convince you that this problem can be
written as a polynomial optimization
problem
what i want to do next is to tell you
that there is a very systematic way to
get a convex relaxation to these
polynomial optimization problems
and this is something that if you
haven't seen in the past i suggest you
really took a look to take a look at
because it's a very powerful tool which
is called uh lasser moment relaxation
so imagine that you are starting from a
polynomial optimization problem these
are tough problems they are non-convex
they are hard to solve in the worst case
what lacer is telling us is that
we can
we can
do a convex relaxation of this problem
and the first step is to define a
monomial basis monomial basis is just a
collection of monomials in this case i
have just two variables x1 and x2 i just
have all the monomials order zero order
one in order to
and then i can define a moment matrix
which is just
the monomial basis as a vector
multiplied its transpose
and even without if you don't understand
the details what you have to think about
is that moment matrix is just containing
all the monomials of the
given order for example from order zero
to order four
and the basic idea is that every
polynomial here assuming these
polynomials are
of order less than 4
can be written just as a linear
combination of monomials therefore can
be written as a linear combination of of
this matrix
so in other words you can rewrite both
the problem objective and the
constraints as a linear function of the
x and as a linear constraint in the x
of course the x is not an arbitrary
matrix has to be positive semi-definite
because of this relation it has to be
rank one but the basic idea in the
relaxation is that we just keep the
positive semi-definiteness constraint
because that's complex and we just drop
everything else which is non-complex
and as a result we get the convex
semi-definite program which is this one
which being convex can be solved in
polynomial time
so look we relax the hard non-convex
problem into a convex relaxation which
can be solved in polynomial time
so presented like this this seems like
you know just heuristic the thing that
is making laser relaxation very
interesting is that
there are very strong theoretical
results telling you that the relaxation
in many cases will get the right
solution it's not going to get you an
approximate solution is going to get you
the right the exact solution to the
problem you relaxed
i don't want you to read all the details
on the theorem i think the theorem is
saying is telling two things
the first one is that
if you make the matrix sex large enough
this relaxation is always going to be
exact
so in other words if you the medic sex
is large enough
you can always solve this problem again
in polynomial time and from the solution
of this problem you can compute a
solution to the original
non-convex problem
can we tell you also something different
we tell you that whenever you solve this
problem and you get a rank one solution
so the x is a matrix whenever the matrix
is rank one
from that matrix you can reconstruct a
solution which is guaranteed to be
optimal for the original problem
okay so there are very strong
mathematical guarantees
and what we notice in practice which is
really motivating us to use these tools
uh imperception problems
is that
we get rank one solution so we get exact
relaxations
even when the size of the x is pretty
small
so in technical terms the relaxation is
tight or exact
at the lowest relaxation order kappa
where the cup essentially is controlling
what is the size of the x
okay so we transformed a problem which
is hard in general into a problem that
can be solved in polynomial time
and we see that for modest dimension of
this problem we can already get optimal
solutions to the original problem
so this is the technical insight
going back like resurfacing a little bit
to the big picture what this technical
insight enabled us to do
is to design really a toolbox of
perception algorithms to solve a broad
variety of perception problems
so right now we have algorithms to to
solve from pose estimation in point
clouds images and trajectory estimation
problems and we have a number of
algorithms to solve that
i'm not going to get into the details
like you know these are graduated and
non-convex and robin are two of the
algorithms but also we have a technique
based on this idea of convex relaxation
to certify that the given estimate is
correct and is optimal or to discard an
estimate as suboptimal that's really the
idea of certifiability
so um just i'm running out of time like
you know i will not tell you like you
know we'll point you to the papers for
the details um i just want to tell you
like in terms of results across many
problems we have a number of algorithms
that you applied to a bunch of different
perception problems for some of them we
also have open source implementations
and the result is that we have uh
algorithms which are able to tolerate an
impressive amount of outliers for
example you can do object pause
estimation from point clouds
even in the presence of 95 percent of
outliers we can get right results
we can estimate pose and shape from
point clouds and be robust to a large
number of outliers
estimate pose and shape for images
of objects from images and get
robustness to 70 percent multipliers and
estimate uh solve robust postgraph
optimization problems can be robust to
again
large number of random outliers which is
really enabling our perception systems
to work robustly in the presence of
for example bad loop closures as i
mentioned before
so i'm running out of time actually we
skipped the last few slides and we'll
jump into the conclusion open problems
and i will i will just go faster this
make sure that you have a little bit of
time for for questions
i'm going to tell you the next couple of
slides what's missing so
so far a lot of work we have done is
about getting certification for these
model-based algorithms which are solving
optimization problems
and at the same time we design very
sophisticated systems right what is
missing really is how to get
certification
not at the algorithmic level but of the
entire perception system so the first
big open problem that we are thinking
about
is how to get performance guarantees for
perception systems not algorithms but
systems
and you can think about perception
systems including a bunch of different
algorithms which are maybe
optimization based or are based on bit
networks the question is if you have a
complex intertwining of algorithms how
can you get
some performance guarantees
and you can break this down into two
questions for example you can ask
can we detect if algorithms are
producing uh are failing are producing
correct results including both
model-based and learning-based
algorithms
or we're also thinking about just a
priori guarantees given a certain
architecture can i quantify what is the
maximum number of failures that i can
detect in that architecture
so big question
system level certification
the other big question is really how to
use um the results that they had
represented today about certifiable
algorithms for optimization
and really use the certifiable
algorithms to kind of self-supervise or
produce certification for learning based
methods
so today what i told you is that
given a bunch of feature measurements i
can solve an optimization problem and i
can get an estimate for example of the
pose of the car but the truth is that
these measurements are typically
features detected by deep network right
so what we are really investigating
right now is how to feedback this
information from our robust estimators
into the neural network and
through this feedback loop we really
hope to get some set supervision and
hopefully to get some performance
guarantees on the performance of the
deep learning based methods
okay so in interest of time i will just
wrap up i think today
i just told you about
the fact that the next generation of
perception systems really requires
hopefully convincing that it requires
high-level 3d scene understanding
including geometry semantics and
relations in real time
and i told you about different systems
towards that goal including chimera
these are your three dynamic scene
graphs and the real real time the recent
real-time effort on hydra
and i also told you that to get real
robust perception we also need better
optimization algorithms to support
different perception tasks and i propose
this mathematical idea of certifiable
perception algorithms
showing you just a few applications to
real problems
and i quickly listed a couple of open
problems about system level
certification and how really to extend
certification to learning based
algorithms
so we'll stop here like hoping that uh
there is some feedback comment or
questions can we stop by just thanking
the sponsors supporting this work and
just thanking you for your
attention was really a lot to digest the
presentation i hope that uh
there was some nice take away at least
yeah thank you so much luca
are there are there any questions
yeah go for it
hi great work i wanted to ask about your
work on certifiable perception
how does the complexity of the algorithm
depend on the input dimension
since it relies on solving sdps i was
wondering about this
yeah the size of the sdp um it's a good
question like you know there are
multiple answers the first answer is
that uh
the size of the sdp
um
i don't know if i can get to the slide i
don't think it's super useful the size
of it is the sdp will grow with
measurements because you have a decision
to make about each measurement being a
liar or outlier
so we go at the same time with the
number of measurements and we'll also go
with
with the size of the x with the variable
that you want to estimate
and at that point how to solve the sdp
there are
lucky cases in which you can the sdp
will have some specific structure which
is amenable for fast algorithms such as
the romanian staircase you can solve
really those in real time
for some other cases you do not have
much structure and we also propose
different algorithms to solve the sdps
in a little bit of a faster way to
leverage the fact that you know that the
the the sap is going to have a rank one
solution so you can leverage the
information to develop a little bit of a
faster solver
uh but in general you have to be careful
on the sdp some algorithms uh maybe like
you know that's a good way to summarize
this um
in this toolbox really um
some of the algorithms are completely
running in real time like robin and
graduated on convex these are fast
algorithms but if you don't really want
to get the certification and you want to
solve yes the largest dp uh you need to
pay a little bit of a computational
price so these two are real time that
running computing at real time this one
requires like a few seconds to run so
it's not real time yet
there is much more to say
the sdp ideas is not only used as i said
for the certification but it's also used
as smaller sizes it is also used in
these other algorithms
um but you know that's a longer story i
will suggest just to look at the
references to get a little bit of a
deeper answer
which is
so if you look at the map in the bottom
left of the truncated least squares box
the
map is probably what some kilometers
across right
and i'm curious if there are any
numerical challenges because if you
usually scale things down to like the
minus one to one box for polynomial
optimization or maybe
there are some tricks where you can get
around
some numbers being very very small and
some numbers being very very large when
you actually have to solve these
optimization problems
i i understand that the question is
about numerical conditioning of
algorithms but i don't understand if
this is referred to this optimization
problem or uh which one
so i think you're you're referring to
this one um
maybe later on to this idea right
this one
um
i don't know like you know the um
i don't know if the numerical
conditioning is the biggest problem for
uh for this i think that
um something that of course is difficult
to see from this slide is that there are
a couple of things which are making
these problems difficult to solve
and the first thing is that these are
what are called degenerate sdps so the
genetic sdps at least we understand it
is that
for a choice of primal variable there is
an infinite choice of dual variables
which are optimal
but anyway there is something generous
in the sdp which is preventing you to
use standard tools for solving like you
know these as the piece
and the other challenge is that uh you
end up having many many constraints so
the size of x is actually not the huge
problem is the fact that at the end of
the day you're going to have a large
number of constraints which are making
this the solution of this optimization
grow a bit slower
um these are the main challenges that we
have seen and if you're curious about uh
what you've done just in terms of
solving the sdp problem
um
you can look at a paper which is called
strides that's an algorithm that we
propose to solve this type of
optimization problems
and inside there is that
is that if you try to solve the sdp
isolation
for example i don't know you can do some
uh
projected building descent on the sdp
right so it's a slow algorithm but you
can do it
you are not really exploiting the
structure because essentially this
problem is a relaxation of
a much lower dimensional problem which
is this guy
so what we do in stride is that
essentially we try to alternate
optimization over this problem
with optimization over these to get a
little bit of a faster convergence
the trade-off is that
this is convex so if you do local
optimization
you get to globally optimal solution but
the convergence might be slow
and instead if you do local optimization
on these convergence is actually very
fast you can do very fast in period
point methods
but this can converge to local minima so
maybe one way to understand stride is
that we do local optimization over this
and whenever we are stacking a minimum
we have to escape the minimum using sdp
that's maybe a good way to describe it
and just to clarify like you know these
these are great questions and of course
it's much beyond what i'm calling the
slides
look at the paper for stride i think we
have cool ideas on solving this faster
but even stride is not is getting us to
solve these in seconds is not real time
full disclosure
there is one question on in the zoom
chat um so it's asking about the
certification step um suppose we cannot
certify the quality of the estimate
do you have suggestions on how a
decision-making algorithm should treat
such a scenario when we cannot certify
the estimate of a car is closed do we
stop or continue assuming there's no
card it's a good question i think there
are two cases in which you cannot
certify there is a case in which uh
maybe your algorithm like you know there
is a case in which the relaxation is
tight so the relaxation is tight but
maybe
your algorithm is a um
yeah i think that's a bit complicated so
so the relaxation is exact right but
maybe you're not solving exactly the
relaxation
and therefore like you know you um
you're stuck in a bad solution
in that case stride again provides a way
to escape this this local minimum so
stride which is this sdp solver that we
have
we provide a way to correct your your
estimate to get it to optimality
but there is also a second case case
which is what you're referring to
probably which is the case in which the
sdp is not exact right
so the good news is that this case in
practice is very rare you use typically
for all perception problems that you
care about with a reasonable number of
outliers this relaxation is going to be
exact which is really one of the most
impressive funding of this work
if it is not tight what happens is that
you solve this optimization problem you
get a solution and the solution is not
rank one
in that case uh really depends on the
task if you want to if you're doing a
very like your safety critical task
maybe you want to reject the solution
and really like not trying to stop the
car or like you know just to have some
mitigation plan
the good news here is that uh whenever
you have a rank to solution like you
know rank more than one solution
this problem can still provide a sub
optimality gap we still quantify how far
you are from the optimal solution so
maybe you can use that information to
say
look if i cannot get an optimal solution
but i'm quite close to optimality maybe
i'm still okay
if instead this about medigap becomes
very large maybe i want to stop my car
and i don't want to trust the estimate
yeah so it's a long answer but i think i
think really depends on your application